Let's go to the phone lines at (617) 830-4750
and see what is on people's minds starting
today with our caller from the two zero four
area code color from two zero four.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Hi David.
My name is Trevor.
I'm calling from Winnipeg, Manitoba up in
Canada.
Hey, how's it going today?
I'm doing pretty good.
Um, I just wanna pick your brain here.
I was wondering why is it that Trump, um,
doesn't seem to attack Bernie as much as everybody
else?
It seems, you know, there's so much, um, you
know, he used to talk about Biden and, and,
and um, Elizabeth Warren and just, but it
just seems like he doesn't, he doesn't push
the, the Bernie thing as much as, uh, as as
much as everybody else.
Uh, do you find that too?
I do find that.
I do think that he has this crazy Bernie nickname
and he's been tweeting about that.
I think there's a couple of possibilities
here.
One is he genuinely doesn't think Bernie is
going to be the nominee, so he feels it's
a waste of time to talk about Bernie.
The other possibility is he's actually scared
of having to go against Bernie in a way that
he's not scared of some of the others, although
it's mere speculation.
I know that there's lots of hardcore Bernie
or busters who say, Bernie is the only guy
that could be Trump.
So Trump is only afraid of Bernie.
I've not seen any evidence of that.
But it is possible that there's something
about Bernie that makes Trump hesitant to
attack them because of what he thinks might
happen if Bernie is indeed the nominee.
But your guess is as good as mine.
Yeah, I think, yeah, I kind of agree with
you that the I, I feel that the only reason
he hasn't really gone after him is, is he's
kind of scared of him.
You know what I, that's the only kind of thing
I could probably think of.
You know,
the only thing is it doesn't really match
Trump's personality.
Trump in general is not really scared of people
other than people who seem to kind of have
them over a barrel.
Right.
Whether it's people who he owes money to or
people bailing him out financially, or whatever
the case, or people who have dirt on him.
I don't know that Bernie falls into those
categories.
So it's, it would be unlike Trump.
But again, we're just kind of speculating
here.
My guess is if it seems clearer after a couple
of primaries that Bernie is a real contender
and starts to accumulate some delegates, my
guest is, you'll see Trump start to attack
him more.
Yeah.
To like that like, yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Like it doesn't seem to be stared at anybody,
so that's why I was so kind of perplexed why
uh, he wouldn't be a full on attacking him
as much as everybody else.
Yeah.
I mean three weeks from now we may be having
a different conversation depending on what
happens.
Trevor, thank you for the call.
Yeah, thanks.
I appreciate your show.
Right.
Great.
Great to hear from you.